yesterday I told you about the first use
as far as we know of the I word
impeachment about Donald Trump by
Democratic senator Blumenthal from
Connecticut in another first democratic
Texas congressman Joaquin Castro who's a
member of the House in telematics
investigating Trump Russia and the 2016
election he said he believes there will
be Trump associates going to jail as a
result of the investigation this is
another first that we have individual
lawmakers talking in these terms
impeachment and jail
here's Castro with Wolf Blitzer on CNN
have you seen any hard evidence of
collusion yet
I guess I would say this that my
impression is I wouldn't be surprised
effort all of this is said and done that
some people end up in jail really
but you think some people are gonna wind
up in jail not just one individual but
people plural is that what you're saying
that's my impression yes including some
who are still who are working in the new
administration or people who work or
advise the president during during the
campaign and maybe during the transition
as you can imagine wolf I'll have to
comment on that later but again if
somebody asked me my impression I would
my impression is that people will
probably be charged and I think people
will probably go to jail without sharing
the evidence because I know it's
classified but do you believe there's
enough evidence already evidence that
you've seen that would justify someone
going to jail or some people going to
jail
if the claims hold up most likely what
the statement from the congressman
suggests is that even with all of the
obstruction by Devin Nunez the guy in
charge of this House committee looking
into the Trump Russia scandal that he
has personally seen evidence that if
true would land people in jail this now
corroborates what the ranking member of
the House Intelligence Committee Adam
Schiff said a couple of weeks ago that
there is now quote more than
circumstantial evidence that there was
collusion between the Trump campaign and
Russia the same week Democratic House
Intelligence Committee member Eric
swallow well
told msnbc quote you can prove a case
entirely on circumstantial evidence
however we also think there is a lot of
direct evidence here intelligence
agencies must know even more than these
guys have seen right they certainly
would but honestly I'm not sure how I
feel about these Democratic lawmakers
sending this information out of course
they're not giving any specifics to the
investigation but it just comes across
as if they're playing politics a little
bit too much and because they're
supposed to be doing a bipartisan
investigation I think maybe they should
just keep those some of the stuff under
wraps I don't disagree with you I don't
disagree with you and I think that also
the risk of this type of thing is if any
of what they start to sort of predict
doesn't happen it looks bad but Donald
Trump must be at least worried to some
degree because he's doing everything he
can to impede the investigations and
distract trying to get the FBI to
denounce New York Times stories about
this throwing smoke bombs like Obama
wiretapped me blocking Sally Yates from
testifying before Congress at this point
things not getting worse is sort of
unimaginable because at some point
something's going to happen I just have
a hard time believing this will
evaporate don't you think and there's
still people out there that say David
you know this is not a story there's
nothing behind the Trump Russia
investigation yeah there's probably
going to be a collusion element that
gets proved in the near future the
problem though is that it's the Trump
Department of Justice that would
eventually be the one to press charges
if they were going to be charges that
Department is run by Jeff Sessions who
is part of the problem he is one of the
guys who's been lying about meetings
with Russian officials he has said he'd
recuse himself from anything related to
Trump and Russia that the Justice
Department might have to deal with but
do any of us believe that he'd have no
influence over the decisions of his
Justice Department even if he was
recused himself from those cases and if
there were impeachment proceedings that
would be done by the House and Senate
which are both operated by Republicans
now so public support for Donald Trump
would have to drop so significantly that
even people in the GOP would have to get
behind his impeachment I hope that the
European countries that have talked
about having intel on Trump Russia
Communications have already been or will
start collaborating with American
intelligence on this because we need
something to move the situation forward
and Devin Nunez is not the path to the
truth on Trump Russia I'm convinced of
that at this point and you know what I
don't even know about the Senate
investigation I know we're saying that
the Senate investigation is is more
objective and fair but I'm increasingly
skeptical of that as well to go back to
the comment that I made before I don't
want to equate what Schiff and what
Castro have been saying with what Devin
Nunez did because the chairman of the
House Intelligence Committee going and
running to the president the subject of
the investigation to keep him briefed on
the esta Gatien that's a whole nother
world there oh absolutely no there's no
comparison and Schiff may be saying more
than they should to the media for
political posturing reasons it's very
different than the person running the
investigation clearly showing that he's
compromised by going and telling the
subject of the investigation what it is
that they have today's episode of the
David Pakman show is made possible in
part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
ones you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription into I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial com /t DPS